zach davies is on the mound for the cubs
he's two and four with a 10 plus era
he's allowed 11 runs on 12 hits
one out and nobody on in our francisco
lindor took another offer last night
lindor just won for 14 on this road trip
has seen his average drop to 171 on the
year
and he drives one in the air to deep
right field bryant goes back takes a
look and it's out of here francisco
lindor with his first home run as a new
york met
a slump buster for lindor and the mets
draw first blood it's one nothing new
york
well francisco lindor has been waiting
for the moments to heat up and he picked
a 39 degree night at wrigley field to
get started new york going with david
peterson a 25 year old left-hander who
is 1-1 with a 6.30 era this season
and so here is ian hemp to lead off a
switch hitter betting right-handed
against peterson here's the one-two
swung on and missed strike three got him
with a change up away
and ian hep is down on strikes
peterson in his last start became the
first met lefty
in 10 years
to strike out 10 and walk none
how many met fans remember who the last
one was
chris capuano
that was a gem that game against the
braves milwaukee's 13 strikeout that was
in 2011 with peterson david looking for
his first big league hit of course in
his rookie season pitchers didn't bat in
the national league he's old for three
so far
it's one and two
winners lead first and second davies to
peterson swing and a miss strike three
and that ends the end
so now jd davis backs with two out and
two on jd
drilled to base it to left field his
first time up at 112 miles an hour
mcneil at second alonso at first with
two down
and jd gets a breaking ball and hits it
sharply base hit in the left center
that'll bring home mcneal alonso to
third jd trying for two the throat
coming in is not in time it's an rbi
double for jd davis he's two for two and
the mets have a two nothing lead not
only two for two but two very hard hit
balls the single to left field in the
second inning and now a well-struck
double here and that's after jd had a
couple of hits including a homer last
night two nothing new york now this is a
big spot
runners at second and third with two
down
michael conforto at the plate
you don't want to be down four nothing
on a night like tonight
zach taking a little extra time now
pauses for the 3-2
the leg kick and the pitch ground ball
toward the middle glove by baez he'll
throw to first in time and that ends the
inning
cubs had the shift on javier the
shortstop over on the right side of
second to make the play
one run two hits two left little third
two down a man at second jeff mcneil the
batter
the 0-1
a little pop fly shallow left-center
baez going out and calling baez makes
the call and the catch
the mets don't score they leave one we
go to the bottom of the fourth inning
new york two cubs nothing rizzo has
always hit lefties pretty well
he hangs in there nicely
the pitch on the way a line driving to
left field falling in for a base hit
rounding third contreras heading to the
plate to throw cut off pub score rbi
single anthony rizzo here's javier baez
who hit the ball hardest first time
grounds win a third a chance for two but
it's bubbled by davis and they get
nobody
a ball hit sharply enough that davis
would have had a chance to think about a
double play and in his haste he commits
his third error of the series to load
the bases
well with the cubs [ __ ] a couple of
their regulars tonight the lineup a
little bit softer
than even usual as matt duffy's the
batter duffy
is just one for 12 so far this year
and the 3-1
duffy will take both four forces in a
run tie ball game
the way duffy reacted ron i believe he
thought that might be called strike two
but the home plate umpire bruce dreckman
said nope it's down low
ball four
and the batter is david bodie infield
back
tie game base is loaded body hits a
little pop fly shallow right center that
ball is going to drop in there for a
base hit baez will score
two runs come in the throw gets away at
the plate and runners are going to end
up at second and third
how do you like that and the cubs on top
4-2
runners at second and third jake
mariznick batting here's the 1-0
mariznick hits the ground ball trying to
score on the play is duffy and he will
the throw goes to first and bodhi moves
up to third now eric sogard
will be the pinch hitter for zach davies
cubs have continued to bang out some
hits sogart lines a base hit into left
center and another run is in it's toward
the gap backhanded by pilar big turn at
first holding with a single soul guard
cubs have scored half a dozen and lead
six to two
half batting from his better side the
left side against the righty gesellman
the selma deals
on the ground lindor
run comes in to score
and now half scrambling back alonzo
out at first
and alonzo tags out
and here's alonso who's had two good at
bats tonight he lined out hard to right
field
and then he came from behind on the
count to work out a walk
against davies in the third
and it's hitting the air in a deep left
field forget that that is way out of
here on to waveland avenue what a bomb
off the bat of pete
alonso he clears the bleachers and hits
it out into the street his third home
run of the year a two-run majestic blast
to cut the cubs lead to 7-4
wow
and matt duffy will bat with the bases
loaded gesellman looks in gets the sign
from the catcher mccann straightens up
he's ready so is
the batter duffy the pitch ground ball
off the mound bounces to the right and
into the outfield one run is in bryant
races around third he's coming home
by his big lead off the third he'll stay
right there
a two-run single for matt duffy and the
cubs extend the lead
9-4 over the mets here in the fifth
inning what a night it's been for the
cubs they're on top of the mets nine to
four
here with just one out in the bottom
half of the fifth inning and then at the
corners
for david bodie 1-1 devotee ground ball
left side picked up by davis throw to
second there's one and no chance for a
throw to first as baez crosses home and
the cubs
tack on another run it's now ten to four
cubs over the mets here on the bottom
half of the fifth inning and baez bats
with the bases loaded and two down
left field
grand slam hobby
and it comes unloading at wrigley
baez circles the bases he'll touch the
plate for the extra point and it's 14-4
davis will begin the eighth
right field shallow long run bryant
coming on and chris makes a sliding grab
well for the second time in his major
league career luis guillermo
is going to pitch it went really well
for him the first time and now javi is
going to take his at bat
and he's going to take it left-handed
now we got a fair fight wow
and a fly ball hit out to left center
hit pretty well but dom smith goes back
to get it
so the left-handed stroke of javi baez
not able to reach the seats and
guillorme has his first down bodhi lines
a base it to center this is going to
drive in rizzo
and the cubs now lead 15 to four and
bodhi has a four rbi game
stopping at second is duffy
jake mareznick lines one day on the left
field line it's fair it's going to drive
in a run the ball bounces around in the
corner body goes to third on a double by
mariznick
and the cubs lead 16-4
well
now pete alonso will bet he's got a long
two-run homer in this game runners at
first and second with two out
in the year
does rizzle have room
he does ball game cubs win